for more on this national border patrol
council president brandon judge just
want to put the mugshot of the suspected
terrorist who was caught um you know
this is something that
kevin mccarthy and congressman cadco
mentioned back on march 15th they were
ridiculed but they were proven right
here's what they said back then
not just people from mexico or honduras
or el salvador they're now fighting
people from yemen iran turkey people on
the on the terrorist watch list they are
catching and they're rushing it all at
once individuals that they have on the
watch list for terrorism
are now starting to exploit the southern
border
we need to wake up
cnn also did a fact check said
fact-checking gop claims that people on
terror watch this are rushing the border
all right so rushing okay fine if they
want to quibble with that but the fact
that you know it only takes one
terrorist
to actually cause a lot of harm and the
fact that yesterday bill millusion told
us they had 11 000 godaways in november
alone sir
yeah when you look at the the total
number of people that are across an
arbor illegally there is a rush now
whether there's a rush of people from
saudi arabia iran iraq you know that
that's a that's a different story but we
do know that we're apprehending people
from 151 different countries including
countries all over the middle east um
countries that have ties to to terrorist
organizations such as eritrea in in
the the african continent so yes we're
apprehending people from everywhere and
then on top of that we're having a
record number of people that are able to
evade apprehension when you go to yuma i
was just there on monday of last week
when you go to yuma 90
of our resources are in processing we
only have 10 of our agents that are on
the border we have we have holes that
are just wide open that criminal cartels
are able to exploit and including
terrorist organizations will be able to
exploit those uh those holes in our in
our coverage as well if they want to so
yes it it exists it's there it's a real
threat now the problem is is why not be
safe than sorry why not open your eyes
to the problem and why not do something
about it and that's what i'm trying to
push this administration to do when you
look at the the filling in the gaps of
the wall that's something that we've
been constantly on them to do and thank
goodness they're actually starting to do
that because that's where all these
people in in yuma are coming through
they're coming through those gaps in the
walls yes they are giving themselves up
but they're still coming through those
gaps yeah you mentioned the country's
151 they're quite stunning they're just
looking at this website pewresearch.org
uh the number of encounters from romania
in the year 2020 was 266.
the number of encounters for people from
romania this year in 2021
is 4029.
um turkey a a year ago it was 67. turkey
this year is 1
300 and it just blows your mind that
sound bite from then candidate joe biden
talking about high tech what have they
done in the last
eight nine ten months in high tech on
the border
nothing at all and it really wouldn't
matter even if you had high tech on the
border all it would be doing is counting
the got aways that that are able to
evade apprehension high tech doesn't do
anything as as far as allowing us to
take people into custody all it does is
tells us where they're at but if we
don't have the resources on the border
to actually take people into custody it
doesn't matter you know one of the
things that i have constantly harped on
dhs to doing is if we were to take these
people if you look at yuma right now
we're shipping people from yuma off to
laredo to be processed why are we
sending people on the southwest border
to another southwest border sector we
just don't have the resources why aren't
we sending them up to the northern
border to process up on the northern
border so that we can have our resources
in the field if we would do that in yuma
if we would take the people that we
apprehended yuma and send them up to the
northern border for processing then we
would have our our people in the field
so this this administration has done
absolutely nothing no policies no
programs no operations no new technology
nothing to secure this border and that's
why we're seeing the influx that we're
currently dealing with you said you're
urging the administration you're talking
to them and urging them do you get a
response ever
uh
lukewarm at best um
you know they they they listen they say
that they listen to what i say but
they're not they're they've never
implemented anything so no i'm not
getting any type of a risk the one last
question here some of the observations
on on crime in some of these big
democratic cities you start to see a
shift
the mayor in san francisco the governor
in california said something about the
other day there may be more of that
have you seen any shift on the border in
this administration at that level
well right now i mean if you look at
what happened yesterday again we've been
we've been yelling at the top of our
lungs to get them to fill in the gaps in
the wall so now they are they are
actually coming in to fill in the gaps
they've got to do something they know
that they have to do something this is a
very small thing but you give me one
foot of wall that's one more foot of
yeah
but you're saying you see some movement
however small that might be correct
yes yes a little bit all right well
we'll see
we'll see how much more you get in 2022
thank you brandon judd for your time
thank you
appreciate it hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now